it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you get to chill out with
mr. freeze as he terrorizes Gotham in
the latest DLC for arkham origins cold
cold heart cool party but this is a
serious game with a new take on that
cold-hearted villain so I would expect
less puns this mr. freeze is kind of
deep and dark and sad ah there we go
kick some ice April 22nd all you pc
owners finally get your chance to light
a high resolution bonfire as dark souls
2 finally makes its way to the master
race but you won't really be paying
attention to how good those textures
look when the tiny pigs from a jeweler
are killing you that bacon is way too
buff start collecting Souls April 25th
speaking of ports trials fusion crashes
its way
current gen 2 pc so you can get every
pixel of detail out of that guy swimming
on the ground
start freestyling april 24th also this
week we get demon gaze a dungeon
crawling game for the PS Vita that
finally releases in North America and
Europe after its initial release in
Japan will this game already seems way
less trashy than conception to the game
allows players to create secondary
characters that join you on your quest
there are 45 character illustrations
altogether and they can be changed by
taking a bath god damn it Japan start
scrubbing up April 22nd and finally nes
remix gets a sequel offering 12 classic
games broken up and mixed with various
challenges featuring super Luigi Bros a
luigi themed remix of super mario bros
where you get Luigi's high jump over
Mario's sad regular jump for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page louise states are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week